the Floyd family has asked if you are
going to get justice for George Floyd by
making sure that the other officers are
arrested and that eventually convicted
there was a moment yesterday where for
the first time you connected the Floyd
family with the police chief and it was
such a beautiful and touching moment
because the police chief was there
amongst the people and he was so human
that's the only way I can describe with
such he was so human what was that like
what was that moment like for you I will
tell you this after that interview I
could not contain myself I have been
pushing my emotions down to my toes
to try and stay in a space that is that
allows me to work that allows me to be a
journalist and do my job I walked away
from that interview and I sat on the
side of the road and I cried like a baby
because he was so honest and I have
never seen a police chief in a situation
where it's his officers who are
literally being accused one of them of
murder so he's got everything to lose
and he was so incredibly honest and this
is Sibley and right now this is the
Floyd family - to the Floyd family and
when he took his cap off when I told her
it was the Floyd family asking these
questions through me
he took his cap off not once but twice
and that kind of respect and compassion
is a rare thing right now and it broke
me down you also during that moment you
couldn't see George Floyd's brother but
he was so emotional I mean and have you
had a chance to see the video now that
it's over and what was your response
when you saw the uncontrollable tears
that poured from that man so that was
really the first interaction that you've
had with the police department since
your brother's death
I could hear him being unable to speak
I just couldn't see him well that's what
started me feeling emotional when I saw
what happened I cried again and I try
not to cry at work that is not what I do
crying I always say is home that's my
policy for myself his reaction to the
chief and the Chiefs reaction to him
I've never seen anything like it
it was the realest moment that I have
probably had in my career between a
police chief and someone who has la lost
a loved one due to a police officer it
couldn't be more real I don't know any
other way to describe it every single
fiber of my body was paining every fiber
every emotion was was just I it was so
hard to contain it I can't tell you Don
what that's doing to me to hear them
have this conversation through me to the
to the chief sorry to hear the pain and
the Floyd family's voice and to have to
convey that I hope that I did the right
thing for them because I know that they
are hurting so so badly in this
situation coming off of coab in nineteen
all of a sudden you're on a plane and
you're in the middle of this people are
out and about how hard is that added
element bin because you know you have to
wear a mask you still have to report you
still have to be amongst the people how
tough is that I think about my safety
far too little sometimes when it comes
to going out into the world going into
war zones going into protests it's
always about trying to get the people's
voices out there and the best story and
you know this tunnel vision you get
tunnel vision but because of coronavirus
because I am also now thinking about my
mother and my husband and my family at
lar it is always in the back of my mind
that after this any one of us here could
go home be infected get sick get really
sick or give it to someone else and kill
someone your family or die yourself I
know the numbers are small when it comes
to percentages of people dying but our
people black folks are being hit
exponentially harder than any other
community so I think about that in the
backdrop of my mind and it is like
living in 1918 and 1968 all at the same
time that's what this feels like
this story has hit home for everyone and
I don't think as a journalist you can
kind of pull yourself apart and say
there are no feelings to this story and
and what is the reasoning behind it
how is that been how is that part of
covering the story extremely
uncomfortable I don't like having my
feelings shown I am supposed to be
objective I'm supposed to be unbiased
I'm supposed to be able to tell a story
from a bit of a distance but I am a
human being like anyone else and when I
need to speak truth I had to speak truth
this time and it was still objective it
was just from looking at a video and
seeing the reaction of people and
knowing this was over a twenty dollar
bill and an accusation that it was
counterfeit $20 seriously so that is why
when you tell a story like this that you
are a human being you can't separate
your humaneness it's because your happen
to be a journalist you can be fair you
can try to be unbiased how you say
things or what you say but the truth is
the truth and I did it with emotion and
it was uncomfortable for me but I
couldn't help it and I'm human beings
[Music]